[Musica]
ciao ragazzi bentornato il nuovo
contratto di cucina buttata oggi faremo
i panzerotti pugliesi
la ricetta l'abbiamo presa dal sito di
sonia peronaci una ricetta che a detta
sua è facilissima secondo me è un buio
devo però come sempre se ci riusciamo
noi che potete riuscire anche voi che ci
state seguendo quindi per partire per
darci una piccola spinta
iscrivetevi a questo canale e poi
naturalmente adesso andrete avanti
dicendo sono in cura
e invece no per favore iscriviti a
questo canale perché io sto per farmi
tre ore di lievitazione per voi c'è chi
potevo uscire andarmi a prendere già
pronti sti cazzo di panzerotti invece
sto facendo lievitare standard a riposta
per tre ore per voi sapete in quelle
terrore quanto mi lievitano altre zone
del corpo che non vi sto a dire
mettetevi una mano sulla coscienza e vi
chiedo solo in tour clicca che vi chiede
quanto 3 attimi di secondo contro le mie
tre ore di lievitazione e vero che poi
viene magno ma magari potrebbe venire
anche una merda che mi mangerò comunque
io sono stanco e a6 vostro test senza un
minimo di apprezzamento quindi se vi
siete iscritti o sotto ore un messaggio
sto lievitando conte e attivate la
campanella che quella lì del timer che
tra tre ore ci dirà che queste cose
hanno evitato iniziamo quindi subito con
gli ingredienti per l'impasto dei
panzerotti pugliesi avremo bisogno di
950 grammi di farina e infinito 250 g di
farina di semola rimacinata di grano
duro come ha fatto a trovarla proprio
lei 270 grammi di 10 grammi di
ritenzione idrica in sali 7 grammi di
lievito di birra pancia e 20 grammi di
oki chiudo libia che non ha mai
conosciuto il sesso
aggiungo la farina poi semola e a quel
punto 7 grammi di lievito disidratato
quello bellezza d'italia in cella in
realtà cosa quella cosa che si dovrebbe
fare l'interno della planetaria ma non
tutti hanno una planetaria quindi devo
dimostrare che si può fare anche chi
mano come facevano i nostri nonni
pugliesi ok i nostri bisnonni pugliese
prende a mensa a questo punto e lo
sciogliamo dentro l'acqua a filo io
adesso inizierò ad aggiungere l'acqua e
pian piano che la aggiungo io vado a
incorporarla finché vedrò che non si
stacca completamente dalle pareti come
in ogni cosa nella vita e anche nelle
associazioni a delinquere sarebbe
comunque costretti dopo un po a
sporcarvi le mani
mamma mia è duro erto semola già re artù
usate come una spugna pulite ecco lo più
molto umido io queste cose le dosi non
capirò mai perché c'è un'altra ancora
dentro problema posso mettere so niente
1 slime dei miei contro tema dio cioè
cosa che mi dispiace a mangiarlo ma
cos'è che penso sia sbagliato a fare
quello che era fatto è questo ho fatto
di allenamenti pallavolo tutti bagheria
di tutti i paletti
certo mi piace allenare perché sono
tesserato invece hanno potuto un
protocollo per poterci allenare lo
indica ci alleniamo nei parchetti coi
coltelli tra i denti vista cioè quello
l'altro conto ma il fatto che la possa
farlo veramente il venuto così bello
l'impasto posso dirlo bellissimo oddio
ributtato il sale po fatica che hai
fatto non lanciato andiamo a oliare di
piano prendiamo il nostro panetto e lo
mandiamo a appiattire perché dovremo
fare delle pieghe sono fondamentali per
la lievitazione se durante la quarantena
de presa anche voi una laurea in
panificatori saprete cosa
le pieghe io l'ho imparato in quarantena
le pieghe di rinforzo ragazzo si
chiamano spiegate gianluigi mg o meglio
andato a recuperare quello del padre del
pane pro lasciamo perché lui spiega
tutto quanto lembo sul lembo joe lamb a
sinistra avremmo a destra rigiriamo
tutto quanto e lo copriamo con una
ciotola per un quarto d'ora modo che non
si secchi rinforzati piccolo sonnino
piccolo sul nilo
attendiamo passate 15 minuti dovremo
rifare la stessa procedura appiattiamo
solo che questa volta quando vado a
piegare chiudo perché secondo me
sbagliato prima lasciando così aperto
chiudeva gianluigi cioè sigillava con
quello lo rifarò una terza volta buona
la prima e li aspettiamo
ma è lievitato secondo te secondo me sta
esplodendo
ma perché così.io e l'altro dividiamo in
sei
dobbiamo fare sei palline la faccio
passare qua come se fosse una bolla di
sapone che continua a spingere spingere
a spingere mentre capito mi aiuto con la
mano a fare la palla e quando mi trovavo
ottimo medusa tipo caciotta chiudo
stringo e poi me la trovo qui è stato
superato ma un'ora in forno spento
per il ripieno dei panzerotti pugliesi
avremmo bisogno di nicola 120 g di finto
sangue per le scene i twilight 60 g di
formaggio grattugiato 150 g di rocco
siffredi ritenzione idrica e un
cucchiaio di olivia che non ha mai
conosciuto il sesso mentre aspettiamo
che lieviti non facciamo di fuggire su
noi stessi e ma a quel punto prendiamo
olio e diamo una bella con di tina
scusami aiuto aspettato vabbè le
riuscite a immaginarlo da soli l'olio
che entrano dentro la passata vi prego
ditemi di si
era una bella sala tina al condimento
bello aggressivi
ricordiamo parla dietro questa ricetta a
me non me ne frega un cazzo
i tuoi reni diventano così perché
serietà minuziano a questo punto rocco
siffredi mazza non tempo
rocco prendiamo a questo punto una
pentola raga questa qui delle cosette
che mi è stata regalata di una pentola
in ghisa la volevo da una vita ed è
stata regalata da questo io capisco che
per 30 anni perché mi commuovo meglio di
un action figure come se simpatico da
marco ma molto poco più per nemo l'olio
in farina ndaw ai correndo troppo per i
gusti scuso viene ragione infariniamo
qua il piano ma non andiamo piano è
passata un'ora
non ce la faccio più ragazze questa
giornata è devastante e molto bello
vedere quello che esce fuori via
bellissimi stravolto ragazzi vi prego
mettete un like per sostenermi perché
cioè sono a pezzi
possiamo soffice sa poniamo con
carineria e piccole riuscita anche sopra
mese c'era un po di farina
iniziamo a stendere 20 centimetri di
diametro
adesso passiamo alla pummarola mi
raccomando ragazzi stiamo distanti
almeno due centimetri e bordi in questo
è quello che ci consiglia sonia
parmigiano mozzarella chiudiamo e
facciamo aderire per bene tutto
con un coltello andiamo a rifinire il
bordeaux perfetto l'olio deve stare a
170 gradi e poi il terrore ad alzarlo e
metterlo a friggere il terrore è umano
per il terrore per oggi ma è inumano
alzare quel corpo sarebbe tragico se si
aprisse perché hai fatto un buon lavoro
fino adesso mi sono fatto un bacio di
fino adesso il cuore ci ho messo il
cuore
ora sta già l'impasto mammamia gianmarco
a parte che schifo come sollevo così ha
senso capito come poi ma dall'altro lato
sempre con nero anni sta innervosendo
volta hanno aiutato ai dati di me non
sono un panzer bouncer of counsel 8
diavolo sotto nei commenti fa un cerotto
gli errori dietro l'angolo e questo cosa
si potrebbe aprire un casinò e tutta la
mozzarella ma lì non ci siamo mai
successo no l'inverno ma se non ti sono
per nicolosi propri male quindi un bene
bravo cauterizza continuare a bagnare
esterno con l'olio caldo lavora per
esplodere
cosa sta succedendo
complimenti signora è un marchio tragga
sta diventando duro allora ragazzi sto
per farlo come si dice sofferto ed è poi
fondamentale questo qui nella è staccato
pregate con me ragazzi lira volta
un'altra volta giravolta o cielo ragazzo
sta avvenendo perfetto da quantum
attenuto oddio deve ingiallirsi 109 83
ragazzi ne facciamo un altro gli altri
congelo il secondo si sta leggermente
aprendo perché più brutti sopra e più si
gonfiano quindi forse quello che
suggerisco io e di tanto in tanto ma poi
lasciarlo stare
piccola fessurina io vorrei rigirare e
vedere che succede nelle sue parti
oppure potrebbe resistere io credo in
lui stupendo adesso sotto si sta aprendo
quindi non è detto però ne ha detto
vediamo che cosa succede
ok questo
questa sera si è aperto ed è utilizzato
dalle migliori oddio ti prego ti prego
questo è un pezzo di formaggio a 170
gradi e vediamo un po
no adesso qualcosa il brano ragazzino
toglierlo non ce la faccio più passiamo
all'assaggio mamma mia che bomba posso
concedermi noi non c'è bisogno che tu
dica niente si capisce cosa sono uno di
vino più piccolo che non era nota
negativa per rega è pazzesco pazzesco
forse era molto grande ed aver fatto più
pieno senza bolle d'aria è incandescente
semplicemente vero ma non avevo
percezione non ce l'ha fatta a mentire
qui l'attesa ne è valsa la pena io non
sono molto abituato a magna sta roba
generale quello vero non curiamo
eccezionale successo ragazzi mi
raccomando se lo perde anche voi taggati
nin su instagram qui all'uscita noi ci
vediamo giovedì in con un nuovo video
ciao
[Musica]